It's a day that ends with Y, so you know what
that means: someone on Reddit thinks they
know what'll happen in the next Avengers movie!
If you want to ensure that the official trailer
reveal has a zero percent chance of being
spoiled, click away now.
For those of you who are still here, let's
get started.
In the lead-up to the launch of Avengers 4
on May 3rd, 2019, internet gossip and rumors
spread faster than Spider-Man decides to ditch
school to fight space aliens.
But even amid this sea of speculation, directors
Joe and Anthony Russo have all but super-glued
their mouths shut in efforts to speak as little
as possible about the movie, even going so
far as to not reveal the film's official title...even
though we're only nine months out from the
movie's release.
But if the latest Internet post to gain traction
is to be believed, all that effort may have
been in vain.
The latest bit of Avengers 4 buzz is that
the title and trailer description has reportedly
leaked online months ahead of time posted,
subsequently deleted, and later re-shared
by several users on Reddit.
Yes, if this post is accurate, Marvel Studios'
efforts at secrecy would seem to have been
an utter failure.
Fortunately for them, the whole thing sounds
way, way too bonkers to actually be real.
The description includes all kinds of exciting,
dramatic details that you'd expect to see
in the Infinity War follow-up's trailer.
We've got a shot of Thanos' "...damaged Infinity
Gauntlet in a field on the farm planet."
We've got Robert Downey Jr. speaking in voiceover,
saying "We were destined to lose."
We've even got, quote, an "epic music score."
You know, as opposed to a trailer with a non-epic
music score...like this:
But those aren't the only details that sound
plausible.
We've got M'Baku sitting on the throne in
Wakanda, taking over for T'Challa while he's
nothing more than a pile of dirty leaves.
We've got Thor and Valkyrie hanging out on
a Kree ship the kind of space vessel Marvel
fans should expect to know pretty well after
Captain Marvel hits in March of 2019.
We've got Hawkeye in full Ronin gear in Japan,
hanging out with the Yakuza.
So far, so possible.
So this description has all the general signifiers
you'd expect out of a trailer for the dramatic
and incredible superhero sequel.
But there are also a few other details in
the supposed trailer description that seem
to throw a whole lot of water on the idea
that it's real.
What kinds of details?
Well, how about the part of the description
where, quote:
"Rocket and Nebula [are] modifying some new
weapons in the lab.
Rocket says 'When can we try this bad boy
out?'
They both smile at each other and fist-bump."
You heard right.
According to this post, Rocket and Nebula...fist
bump.
"That's gross."
That's not the only head-scratcher in here.
The description says that after the movie's
title is revealed to be "Avengers: Annihilation,"
we'll get a shot of Black Widow, Captain America,
and the Hulk training at a new SHIELD facility:
"Steve notices that Hulk has been training
non-stop as of late, so he asks why.
Hulk responds in Banner's normal voice with:
'My rematch is coming real soon, I can feel
it!'"
Those details, among others, have left the
commenters on Reddit to conclude that the
post is pretty far from legit.
Highlights of other Redditor's reactions include,
quote, "This is such utterly trash fanfiction
I can't believe anyone thought it was real,"
and "Sounds like something Goku would say."
"Wow!
That guy's awesome!"
And while the addition of Goku to Avengers
4 would probably make the movie about a thousand
times more amazing, it's hard not to agree
that some of the details listed in the description
do seem a little difficult to believe.
So is this description possibly the real deal?
Or the product of one fan's imagination after
spending months reading rumors and theories
on the Internet?
Either way, in the absence of official trailers
or details from Marvel Studios, random Reddit
threads are pretty much all fans have to go
on.
The hype for Avengers 4 is crazy high, and
fans are getting tired of waiting for the
movie to hit already.
Hopefully we'll get a glimpse of the official
trailer soon, and we can know the truth for
sure.
In the meantime, let's all just get serious
for a second this is probably what the next
Avengers trailer is going to be like...for
real: